مجرد قلم واحده تحرم النساء والفتيات في
افغانستان من اكثر الاشياء ضروره للانسان
في حياته التعليم والعمل الوضع خاتم في
كابول القرار وتخذ رغم انف الحريه الشخصيه
هناك السيدات ليس لهن مكان في المجتمع
الافغاني الزميله العزيزه دائما نادين
خماش كانت مفاده العربيه الى افغانستان
قبل اسابيع من الانسحاب الامريكي منها
وعوده الحكم فيها الى حركه طالبان فماذا
رصدتنا جين هناك في ذلك الوقت وكيف اصبح
ما تخيلته في تلك اللحظات تعيشه السيدات
الافغانيه
[موسيقى]
ليست ضفتنا لكنها من اهل البيت
اليوم تجربتها في افغانستان قبل عام
وانت معايا
من اول ما جينا مع بعض حتى هلا عم نعمل
مقابله مع بعض طيب نادين الحلو انه كان
عندك فرصه قبل سنه من الان قبل سيطره
قبل سنه من اليوم
لما نحنا رحنا قبل عام تقريبا
اول ما بتوصل لمطار حامد كرزاي في كابول
بتستقبلك في الامن العام سيدات يعني تخيلي
واجهت افغانستان للعالم عم نحكي وقتها قبل
عام واجهه افغانستان العالم كانت سيدات
على الامن العام بيختموا الجوازات
بيستقبلوكي في ابتسامه اهلا بك في كابول
فبتوصلي انت في العاصمه الافغانيه طبعا
اكيد بده يكون في عندك شويه خوف من النظره
الصور النبطيه البلد مش مستقره يعني كل
حياته بتلاقي انه نساء كانوا موجودين في
كل مكان يعني زي ما انا مثلا هلا هون
عمالي كنت بعمل كيس كاميرا وراي سيدات عم
بيمشوا كانوا عملهم بتسوق والسوق كان
مليان بني نساء من سيدات كانوا حتى
المقاهي المطاعم الموجودين بكثره كانوا
يشعروا بالامان كان يشعروا بالراحه زي ما
انا شايفه هون انا لابسه همم خلفك هذا كان
تصوير بمرض هذا معرض كان اسبوع
فبالتالي كان في كثير دور للمراه
الافغانيه وكانت تريد ان تكون الى جانب
الرجل بمساواه مع الرجل للنهوض في المجتمع
على صعيد اقتصادي وعلى صعيد اجتماعي فهن
انا كنت عمالي بتسوق في معرض هذا معرض
اسبوعي كلها نعمل سيدات نسائي نساء
موجودين بس كمان ملاحظه سهام خصوصا بلحظات
الاخيره والاسابيع الاخيره كان كثير في
عندهم خوف كانوا دائما يخافوا وكان عندهم
نظره رؤيه قويه اكثر من مراكز صنع القرار
والدراسات التي تحدثت عن مستقبل افغانستان
اليوم خصوصا بعد سيطر الطالب كانوا يقولوا
انه نحن كان نساء عدو طالبان كانوا خائفين
خائفين مما بعده كانوا يطالبوا انه يا
عالم انقذونا انا بعرف واحده من السيدات
سهام قبلتها افغانستان كانت واحده من اقوى
100 سيده صنفت دوليه هذه السيده كانت تعيش
بكام الحريته والامان وفخوره بنفسها وكان
في سيراتو يعملوا له في البرلمان الافغاني
اليوم بعد الحركه هربت وغادرت الى بلاد
اخرى بسبب
على راس قائمه فورس طيب نادين انت كنت
حاورتي قياديين طالبان واخذتي وعود منهم
بعد ما اهتميت وسالتي عن وضع النساء بعد
سيطره الحركه
هذا اللي بلشت فيه حديث سهام انه ربما
كانت هذه تصريحات اعلاميه لكسب راي العام
الدولي فكان في تطمينات لان طالبان اليوم
ليس طالبان الامس نحن نجاري تكيفات في
المجتمع ونحن وزنه طمئن المجتمع الافغاني
بانه كل شيء سيكون سليم حتى تصريحات قاده
في طالبان كان يقول لهم النساء سيذهبنا
الى التعليم وهي موفقه بالفيديوهات في
مقابلات سابقه وفي اكثر من مقابله اجرينا
هذا ان النساء سيذهبنا الى التعليم سهام
كمان ممكن احنا نسال نفسنا والعالم ممكن
تسال احنا شو بيفيدنا او موضوع افغانستان
بعيد كل البعد عنك كيف نحن سنه تاثر نحن
كعرب او دول الاقليم او دول في العالم كيف
يعني هذا هو السؤال انه اذا افغانستان
بعيده كل البعد عنه انا اقول لك بان
العالم كان في السابق كانت جزر كانها
منعزله اليوم بفعل العولمه نحن مدينه
صغيره نحن مدينه كبيره كمان فبالتالي
عندما كان تخرج العناصر المتشدده كانوا
يعيشون في قاسي الجبال واعالي الجبال
لوحدهم اليوم اي شخص ارهابي متشدد يحمل
فكر متشدد بيحمل حاله بهالطياره وبيروح
على اي بلد ممكن يعني يقوم باي عمل اجرامي
ام عمل ارهابي فبالتالي العالم مفتوح انت
كمان ليش طالبان تخشى من النساء لانه
مجابهه النساء تمر عبرهن كيف يعني انا لما
بدي اخلي امنع النساء عن التعليم معناته
انت عم تمنعي مجتمع كامل من التعليم لانه
الجاهله ستربي جاهل بالتالي سيكون هناك
خطر التنشئه الاجتماعيه في المنزل اللي هو
صوره مصغره عن المجتمع ش- ستكون خطيره جدا
يعني عندما نمنع النساء عن التعليم فنحن
سننشا وسنربي اجيال وسانولد اجيال تكون
مشروع ارهابي مشروع متشدد في المستقبل ان
يكون قنبله موقوته في اي وقت فبالتالي لا
تريد طالبان ان يكون للمراه صوت مسموع هذا
الصوت اللي هو لكي تكون هذه البلاد تعيش
بصوره حضاريه هذه البلاد التي لم تهدا
ابدا بس سؤال اخر نادين يعني شفنا اهتمام
كبير ليس من الناحيه السياسيه ولكن اهتمام
دوري كبير حتى على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الملف لم يكن السياسيا فقط ولكن
ملف اجتماعي بالاهتمام الكبير ما رايك
بهذا الاهتمام الذي به الملف والسهام انا
واياك كل يوم نتحدث في هذا الموضوع انه
حرمان نساء من التعليم هلاكم ان تتخيلوا
ونتخيل معا ان يكون هناك مجتمع نسائه غير
متعلمات ماذا نتوقع وماذا نستشرف في
السنوات المقبله اي مستقبل ينتظر هذا
البلد سواء هذا البلد هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه التي قد تكون بعيده عنا ولكن
عندما تمتد الى اقاصي هذا العالم فهنا
ياتي الخطر وابعد من ذلك شكرا لك